as day draws to a close in the Norwegian
ski resort of yellow and the temperature
plunges to well below freezing you
sometimes hear strange sounds for miles
around once a year one of the strangest
and certainly coldest music festivals in
the world takes place here on a frozen
lake the musicians play instruments made
entirely out of ice the audience members
are impressed
I'm still wondering how they made it but
it looks amazing to experience
in the forest on the water it's magic
Sara Willis who plays French horn with
the Berlin Philharmonic attended the
festival this year and she reported on
it in her weekly DW classical music show
Sara's music Norwegian percussionist
Tara is on set came up with the idea for
the festival in 2006 he has an
ecological message changed some of those
things on the ISIS bill and I think to
deal with ice and water
becomes very important to us the
comments to all those things the annual
festival lasts three days and always
attracts thousands of visitors
the 26 musicians who will perform make
their instruments themselves almost at
the last minute before the concerts they
use ice that's been collected from the
frozen lakes around it takes some time
to fine-tune the instruments and find a
suitable sound we try new things I
normally my job is to come up with
Eddie's put together the program the
artistes so this year we have this
enormous tuba a kind of thing but we
also have the drums the African style
drums that we haven't done before the
annual highlight is the midnight concert
on yellows frozen lake it's improvised
from beginning to end
the musicians never know if their
instruments will survive the to our
concert they tend to melt and the sound
changes accordingly
this is strange and unique music
performed in the Arctic chill